E
HAVE PLENTY OF INSIGHT AT
CNN.COM OR OF COURSE UNDER CNN
APP ON YOUR SMARTPHONE.
AND TO THE PART OF THE WORLD
WHERE I AM TODAY, RELATIONS
BETWEEN SAUDI ARABIA AND THE
UNITED STATES, THEY HAVE BEEN
STRAINED OF LATE.
THAT IS AFTER OPEC PLUS DECIDED
TO SLASH OIL PRODUCTION AND
WASHINGTON HAS NOT HELD BACK IN
ITS REBUKE OF THE KINGDOM.
AND JOE BIDEN TELLS CNN THAT
WASHINGTON MUST RETHINK ITS
RELATIONSHIP WITH RIYADH.
IT WAS PARTICULARLY STINGING
BECAUSE MR. BIDEN'S EFFORTS,
JUST MONTHS EARLIER, TO REPAIR
IT TIES WITH SAUDI ARABIA.
THE U.S. PRESIDENT WAS WELCOMED
ON THE TARMAC BY THE KINGDOM'S
AMBASSADOR TO THE U.S.,
PRINCESS RIMA --
REEMA BINT BANDAR AL SAUD, THE
ONLY SIDE IN THE ROOM WITH HIS
HIGHLANDS TO PAINTED MEETING
WITH CROWN PRINCE MOHAMMED BIN
SALMAN.
PRINCESS REEMA BINT BANDAR AL
SAUD TOOK ON THE ROLE AT A
PARTICULAR LOW POINT IN SAUDI
U.S. RELATIONS.
IT WAS MERE MONTHS AFTER SAUDI
JOURNALIST JAMAL KHASHOGGI WAS
KILLED IN THE SAUDI CONSULATE
IN ISTANBUL.
SHE HAD A TOUGH TASK OF MANY
RELATIONS BACK, THEN AND IT
SEEMS LIKE SHE IS BACK AT IT
NOW.
I SAT DOWN WITH PRINCESS REEMA
BINT BANDAR AL SAUD TO DISCUSS
ALL OF THAT IN THE KINGDOM'S
ROLE IN ENERGY SECURITY.
I STARTED BY ASKING HER, TO
DESCRIBE THE TONE OF CURRENT
SAUDI U.S. RELATIONS.
HAVE A LISTEN.
>> IT IS A CLEAR POINTED
DISAGREEMENT.
AND OBVIOUSLY, THAT COMES FROM
THE DECISION OF OPEC+ TO CUT
THE PRODUCTION OF OIL AND I
WOULD HAVE TO JUST REMIND
PEOPLE THAT IT WAS A DECISION
MADE BY 22 COUNTRIES BASED ON
AN ECONOMIC SURVEY THAT
UNDERSTOOD THAT THERE IS GOING
TO BE A DOWNTURN AND MANY
PEOPLE HAVE TRIED TO POLITICIZE
THIS.
BUT YOU ARE HEARING IT FROM THE
HORSE'S MOUTH.
THIS IS NOT POLITICAL, THIS IS
PURELY ECONOMIC BASED ON THE
EXPERTISE OF 40 OR 50 YEARS OF
MAPPING ENTRANCE.
WE DO NOT ENGAGE IN THE
POLITICS OF ANYONE.
WE ENGAGE AS A BALANCER IN
DISTURBED STABILIZER THE
ECONOMY THROUGH THE ENERGY
MARKET AS WE'VE DONE
HISTORICALLY.
>> LET ME PROVIDE AS A COUNTER
ARGUMENT, THAT FROM A WHITE
HOUSE PERSPECTIVE, THE WHITE
HOUSE HAS ACCUSED SAUDI ARABIA
OF SIDING WITH RUSSIA.
IS THE KINGDOM SIDING WITH
RUSSIA?
>> THE KINGDOM HAS A POLICY OF
ENGAGING WITH THOSE ACROSS THE,
BOARD IN THOSE THAT WE AGREE
WITHIN THOSE DON'T AGREE.
WITH THE RELATIONSHIP THAT WE
HAD WITH RUSSIA IS WHAT ALLOWED
US TO FREE PRISONERS OF WAR TO
AMERICANS, FIVE BRITONS, ONE --
AND A SELECTION FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES.
WE VIEW OUR ROLE AS A MEDIATOR
AND A COMMUNICATOR.
WE SUPPORTED HUMANE --
UKRAINE HUMANITARY LIAM --
WE COLLABORATE WITH UKRAINE
POLAND TO GIVE TO MILLIONS OF
THE REFUGEES ARE COMING OUT OF
UKRAINE'S BILLION TO POLAND A
SAFE LANDING.
THAT IS WHAT WE DO.
THAT IS THE VALUE OF OUR
ENGAGEMENT.
IS IT SIDING WITH RUSSIA?
NO.
WE VOTED WITH THE UNITED
NATIONS.
TWICE, TO CONDEMN THE
ANNEXATION AND CONDEMNING THE
INCURSION.
WE ABSOLUTELY VIEW THE DECISION
BY OPEC AS NON POLITICAL, AND
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MARKETS,
BECKY, WHAT HAPPENED?
THEY ARE STABLE.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS THAT
THEY KNOW THE DECISION WILL
INCREASE RUSSIAN REVENUES AND
BLUNT THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
SANCTIONS.
HAVE YOU PERSONALLY SPOKEN TO
THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT THIS?
WHAT IS THE COMMUNICATION THERE?
>> IDEAL VERY REGULARLY WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION.
IT'S A ADMINISTRATION I HAVE
THE MOST RESPECT.
FOUR AND HAVE THE MOST GRACIOUS
INDIRECT MEDICATION.
THAT'S UP ARTIST MEDICATE WITH
EACH OTHER.
BY THE WAY, IT IS OKAY TO
DISAGREE.
BUT THE IMPORTANT THING IS THAT
RECOGNIZING THE VALUE OF THIS
RELATIONSHIP.
OUR RELATIONSHIP BY THE WAY IS
MORE THAN THE SALE OF ARMS, IT
IS MORE THAN THE EXCHANGE OF
OIL.
IT IS ABOUT THE PEOPLE TO
PEOPLE RELATIONSHIPS, AND YOU
ARE GOING TO SEE IT AT THE F I.
THE NUMBER OF U.S. BUSINESSES
THAT ARE WORKING HERE BECKY,
WHY ARE THEY HERE?
OPPORTUNITY.
AND YOU'VE SEEN IT.
>> JOE BIDEN, THE U.S.
PRESIDENT, SAYS THAT THERE WILL
BE CONSEQUENCES FOR THE ACTIONS
TAKEN BY SAUDI ARABIA AS THE
LEAD MEMBER OF OPEC.
SEVERAL LAWMAKERS HAVE TOUTED A
NUMBER OF PUNITIVE MEASURES,
THE STOPPING OF ARMS SELLING TO
THE SAUDIS AND PULLING U.S.
TROOPS OUT.
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE?
TO JOE BIDEN.
AND TO THOSE LAWMAKERS, AND HOW
CONCERNED ARE YOU ABOUT THESE
CONSEQUENCES?
>> I HEAR A LOT OF PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT REFORMING OR REVIEWING
THE RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
KINGDOM, AND I THINK ACTUALLY
THAT THAT IS A POSITIVE THING.
THIS KINGDOM IS NOT THE CASE
WAS FIVE YEARS, AGO IT'S NOT
THE KINGDOM WAS TEN YEARS AGO,
SO EVERY PIECE OF ANALYSIS THAT
EXISTS, IT IS NO LONGER
RELEVANT.
WE ARE A YOUNG POPULATION.
WE HAVE YOUNG LEADERSHIP AND WE
HAVE AND ASPIRATION IN A GOAL
TO ENGAGE WITH THE WORLD IN A
WAY THAT WE NEVER DID BEFORE IN
THE TRANSFORMATION THAT IS
HAPPENING IN THE KINGDOM IS ONE
THAT THE WORLD SHOULD BET ON
BECAUSE IT WILL NOT ONLY
TRANSFORM US BUT IT WILL CREATE
THIS OTHER PILLAR OF HOPE THAT
IS COMING FROM A DAIRY DARK
REGION.
>> YOU RECENTLY ARGUED IN AN
OP-ED FOR POLITICO, WHICH I
THOUGHT WAS FASCINATING, THAT
RELATIONSHIP SHOULD TAKE ON A
NEW FORM, AND LET ME JUST QUOTE
YOU HERE BECAUSE YOU SAID LONG
GONE IN THE DAYS WHERE THE U.S.
AND SAUDI RELATIONSHIP COULD BE
DEFINED BY THE OUTDATED AND
REDUCTIONIST SECURITY PARADIGM,
THE WORLD HAS CHANGED, AND THE
EXISTENTIAL DANGERS FACING US
ALL, INCLUDING FOOD AND ENERGY
SECURITIES, CLIMATE, CHANGE
CANNOT BE RESOLVED WITHOUT
INEFFECTIVE U.S. SAUDI
ALLIANCE.
>> WHEN WE COME TO AMERICA, AND
WE'RE, SAYING WE ARE YOUR
PARTNER IN ENERGY, HOLISTICALLY,
IT MEANS THAT WE WANT TO DO
BUSINESS WITH.
YOU WE WANT TO INVEST IN YOUR
COMPANIES.
WE WANT TO MAKE YOU AS GOOD AS
WE ARE AND WE WANT TO HAVE THIS
NEXT CHAPTER OF CLEAN ENERGY AS
A PARTNERSHIP.
BECAUSE WHAT WOULD THAT LOOK
LIKE?
THAT IS THE FUTURE, BECKY.
TH